Brett Kavanaugh story has heard an awful
lot of people already but the biggest
victim may be America's basic sense of
justice norms like the presumption of
innocence due process fairness itself
have all been shoved aside in a
political frenzy question is could
tomorrow's hearings start to undo the
damage joining us now is a man who has
relentlessly defended fairness at great
personal cost and even when it has
worked against the interests of the
party he votes for the Democrats use of
course alan dershowitz retired harvard
law professor the author of the case
against impeaching trump and we welcome
him now professor thanks very much for
coming on thank you so what do you want
not as a partisan or some new votes for
Democrats but as someone who cares about
preserving our justice system what do
you want to see in these hearings
tomorrow I want to see the greatest
engine of truth ever invented used
effectively namely cross-examination and
I'm worried that we don't have the right
people the woman who has been hired to
conduct the cross-examination has
probably rarely ever cross-examined
anybody she's a prosecutor
prosecutors put on cases mostly
defendants Democrat the stand and so
this is a woman with twenty years of
experience as a prosecutor but no
experience as a defense attorney so I
don't think she's the right person to
question dr. Ford and there needs to be
cross-examination not only of her but of
the new avenatti allegation that
affidavit is so deeply flawed and so
open-ended that any good lawyer any good
defense attorney would be able to tear
that apart in 30 seconds it's an
embarrassment to the law that anybody
would file an affidavit like that filled
with hearsay filled with well I was
raped but he didn't rape me
he was there he saw it where was he
there are witnesses people told me it
happened 10 times I went back I knew
there were rapes going on but I went
back to the party this is such a deeply
flawed affidavit stalking they're
naughty yeah well let me ask you about
that is this affidavit does it cross
some line where there could be
professional consequences there is a
our association that gives out legal
licenses could they act on that well no
I don't think it reaches that line but
it certainly is an extraordinarily weak
affidavit I want to know who drafted it
I'd want to know why they didn't fill in
the gaps
if I were people who saw this name them
was she raped does she say by Cavanagh
by judge did she did he see it was he in
the room why why didn't if they were
gang rapes like that how did it not get
to the police it's a shocking affidavit
and any lawyer who loves
cross-examination would love nothing
more than to examine a witness holding
that affidavit in his hands saying hear
hear hear
but Abbott suddenly doesn't care about
that all he cares about is getting the
headline the headline has been gotten
maybe she'll testify maybe she won't but
if she testifies she'll be
cross-examined in a very effective
manner by a good cross-examine I wonder
though are we reaching a place where the
social pressure on all of us not to ask
real questions not to see if the claims
align with common sense has become so
intense then everyone's too afraid to
ask real questions oh it's terrible
because she had a woman today on
television saying it's sexist to have
appointed a woman lawyer she would have
said it was sexist to appoint a male
lawyer you need a gender-neutral robot
now to cross-examine if you want to
avoid claims of sexism it's a no-win
cross examination must be effective and
it must be tough it has to be respectful
you can be respectful and tough but do
not pull punches there's so much at
stake here a man's life is reputation
his career his family the women their
credibility the people of America having
a justice sitting on the Supreme Court
the stakes are too high look I don't
agree with the Republicans that you have
to take a vote on Friday I don't agree
with the Republicans that there
shouldn't be a continuing background
check there's no reason not to have a
background check time should not be the
determining factor when you're putting
somebody on the Supreme Court for a
lifetime truth has to be the determining
factor we can't
this vote happen until we know whether
these serious allegations did or did not
occur and there can't be a presumption
of guilt there can't be a presumption of
guilt no you're one of the very few who
is saying that this moment must be
driving you crazy professor thank you
very much thank you